[Music]
and
a
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
them MAA appears to love
fentol of sanus has heard
this you think he knows that the people
that he's trying to uh court or mailing
fentanyl to election officials I don't
know I mean maybe he does maybe he
doesn't sounds like sounds like maanga
to me I mean they're the ones who deem
themselves we are all domestic terrorist
yeah we know we
know apparently um there's several
several letters that have been Fenton
all least around the country now this is
you know this narrative that is going to
happen here because obviously um I think
ratburger this morning one of them was
sent to their office to Brad ranis smis
patis bger down in Georgia you
know speaking of ranis burger ranis smis
bger you know that guy voted for Trump
did you know
that you think that a guy who voted for
Trump who counted the votes fairly in a
red State wouldn't be getting uh
fentanyl lace
letters you think in normal times but
this isn't normal
times this isn't normal times because
they've lost their [__]
minds I I I I don't know who this person
is my guess is it's it's a white dude
he's a tub of lard and he probably lives
in a cabin somewhere in the woods and
he's probably got all kinds of
PE it's probably that dumb [__]
that stands out in his yard you know
with the guns stabbing the dummies and
[__] what do you want from
me you don't think that that's what's
going to
happen [__] the remember the what was
the what was the chuckleheads name out
in Colorado or was it Utah [__] I don't
remember there's so many of these
goddamn white domestic terrorists these
white Christian nationalist these q and
Honors that have been [__] just
diluted by telegram 100% 100% this
[__] whoever it is got a
telegram
account they're GNA find him have you
heard of the udab bomber
before have you heard of it did you know
after the a bomber the United States
puler Service is like you know what
maybe we should track those packages
maybe that's what maybe we should find a
way that way if we need to track someone
that'd be a good
idea how the [__] don't these people
know this they know oh my God they know
the truth about the election they know
what GMO and where Obama is don't they
they know where all the votes were
stolen you just got to do your research
but they don't do their research to know
that when you Mail
envelopes in the United States Postal
Service which is
a a federal government
agency it's literally the only one
that's in the
Constitution they don't even know that
they can track [__] packages are you
serious they they're they know
everything about [__]
vaccines they know everything about
voting machines they're
experts on classified document law folks
these people are online Facebook
experts on coid and
vaccines and they don't know this dummy
doesn't
know that they can track a package and
an envelope not only that the [__]
idiot sends multiple envelopes to
multiple [__] places in the
country to multiple election offices
what are you what what are you [__]
dumb so now now not only do they have
one package they got severals to track
it where it came from what a [__] Bon
head but it is not
surprising now the narrative around this
is going to be shaped and we got to
shape it now that's right we have to
shape this now that's why I'm going to
talk about this story
today because the right see Joe Baden
Joe Biden he took money Ukraine Hunter
Hunter and then fental and then out Brad
ratburger fent all letters oh boy that's
the [__] that'll spit out of the
[__] idiot
machine Joe
Biden Joe Biden did the thing with the
the fentol and the in the
Border they talked a lot about
fentol at this last
debate remember problem Swami I talked
about it was it yesterday I talked about
this [__] I don't
remember V God I can't wait for that guy
to be Andrew yanged can you oh man so V
talks about he wants a border wall on
can build a wall and candada will pay
for it
because fentanyl because he's like
they're stopping Fentanyl coming through
ports of entry in Canada yeah that's
where people come through the border is
ports of
Entry [__] even even fentanyl at the
southern border most of it comes through
the Port of Entry and oh by the way the
people carrying in AC cross through the
ports of Entry are US
citizens [__] Bon heads and the Biden
Administration and the border patrol
under the Biden Administration has
seized more fentanyl than the last dumb
[__] huh I wonder why Trump and
his allies would want fentanyl to pour
into this country is it so they can
grind it down and Lace letters with
it I don't know I'm I'm just asking
questions can't we ask questions isn't
it questions that we can ask speaking of
question questions that we could ask
about fentol when they find this fentol
fiend this manga fentol Fe because there
listen it is not antifa sending [__]
Lac letters to Brad
ratburger okay not a
thing not they're not atifa is not
concerned about the election officials
who are counting the votes of
antifa who is stomping your ass in Ohio
and Virginia and Kentucky
not really concerned about the people
counting those votes they are they're
concerned about the people trying to
cheat in
elections like I don't know
MAA the
fascist Jesus [__]
Christ like uh Tate Reed down in uh
Mississippi where he's like
oh you got a Precinct with a lot of
black voters make sure they don't get
ballots let's make sure they don't get
ballots and let's really try to close
those polls before those people are
allowed to vote in that Precinct that
priest that specific one [__] out of
here it's ridiculous to even dream up
that somehow this is a false flag or
some dumb [__] and the wri's already
doing it online oh God you can Garing
goddamn de it when it's obvious that a
manga domestic terrorist is behind this
[__] boy they come up with a lot of
[__] reasons why it's not what we're
not the domestic I swear I mean we put
it on a big billboard at CPAC down in
Texas we're not we're I swear to you
we're not the domestic terrorist yeah
okay I put it on the thumbnail if you
want the proof you know a lot of people
are gonna you know oh my God this is
liable that manga's terrorists they are
terrorists they call themselves [__]
terrorist for crying out loud what do
you want from
me what the [__] do you want from me
just pointing out the [__] [__]
they're saying [__] speaking of
questions and what they're saying back
to what I was trying to get to with
Ronda santis Hey Ron can we can we get
Ron on the phone I want to ask that
[__] a question the question
would be
this hey high
heels let me ask you something since you
want to execute people at the border
because they're brown and it looks like
they got a backpack on and that backpack
could possibly have fentanyl so you want
to skip over due process of law and you
want to just execute them he [__]
said this [__] on stage he's been saying
it that he wants to execute people at
the border because they're brown well I
mean they had backpacks you know people
traveling you know what do they need a
bag for the only reason why a brown
person would need a bag traveling is
because they're carrying fit off right I
mean come on Ron right am I right so
what are you going to do Ron are you
going to call for this person to be
executed on site is that what you're
going to call for just shoot him just
[__] shoot him no [__] due process of
law [__] it I'm asking Ronda sanis this
should we just execute this
person I mean he's probably one of your
[__] voters if you want to know the
honest truth he's probably in The Shard
Army he's probably one of the Avid
[__] soldiers of The Shard
frankly this guy's a really loyal
soldier in The Shard
Army [__] he's willing to go he's
willing to go to federal prison for
terrorism just like the people who storm
the capital trying to go to [__]
prison just to overturn the election to
have their musolini Jesus as the king of
America don't get mad at
me because I tell tell the truth okay
yeah
fine but Ron really honestly Ron tell me
are we just going to execute this person
is that what we should do especially
when we find out that they're a manga
domestic terrorist and they're not only
trying to intimidate election workers
but they're trying to kill them trying
to poison them with fent and all that's
the really funny part isn't it I mean
come on that's that's hilarious that
manga's like oh it's fit all that's
destroying our country and it's j bad
with the fit all the border and fitting
on border and fitting on Biden border
and Ukraine Hunter Biden laptop
dickpics I look at my son's porn on his
phone with an
app seems to be the [__] they want to
talk
about but as soon as a manga terrorist
uses fentanyl shh don't say anything
about don't say anything about that I
don't know talk about
that
sh
oh man MAA loves
fentol did you I I bet I bet if you go
and you do per capita
numbers of people who are using ventar
in this country oh man 100% it's real
[__] areas 100% there's no [__]
jobs and the jobs that they do have
[__] suck the housing's
horrible the healthcare services there
are abysmal if they exist at all they're
destroying their [__] Public Schools
they're getting rid of their [__]
libraries [__] these people don't have
anything to do but [__] drugs are you
kidding
me destroying Republicans are destroying
rural communities so that way they can
blame it on Democrats they've been doing
it for decades oh they've been doing a
bang up job trust me I [__] come from
the son of a
[__] I mean here in Missouri the
Republicans [__] about how bad their
state is Republicans have [__] had
their their grip of power on Missouri
for decades and they're blaming it on
Democrats what the [__] are you talking
about
man you've been running this state
forever and you're gonna blame it on
Democrats Democrats can't do [__] in
Missouri the only thing the only thing
that people who believe in Liberty can
do in any any of these red States is get
a referendum on the
ballot and honestly there States like
Missouri now they failed last session
last legislative session last year they
well this year the beginning end of last
year beginning of this year they failed
to change the refer referendum laws here
in Missouri they were trying to make it
to where people couldn't get referendums
on the ballot hell the [__] fascist
the fascist Secretary of State here in
Missouri John ashcraft's son Jay
Ashcraft that [__] [__] that
motherfucker's trying to keep trying to
keep a woman's Reproductive
Rights Initiative off the ballot and
it's a referendum of the people
people they love [__] fent all they
[__] love it they hope fentol pours
across the border they hope fentol gets
into these rural communities and
destroys lives so they can blame it on
someone else and try to get elected on
it not try to fix the problem oh [__]
that [__] Republicans never try to
[__] fix problems hell to the no if
it's a problem they create they blame it
on someone else and if it's a problem
they create they blame it on someone
else and try to get elected doing it
you're going to watch this with the
government shutting
down yes they're going to shut down the
government I've been i' I've been
telling you that for a long time they're
going to shut down the government do
Donald Trump doesn't want the government
open they are a [__] authoritarian
party and Donald Trump doesn't give a
[__] about the consequences of anything
because he's a
bonehead so they're gonna shut down the
government it's gonna happen
oh and this morning this is another
thing I was listening to Morning Joe
this morning because I wanted to
see if they had changed their minds
about the polls nope nope now no I'll
admit I'll admit Joe scarber this
morning this son [__] he was defending
Joe Biden in his age which I mean I
don't know why it's such a big deal that
that people think Joe Biden's old he is
old so is Trump they're both old they're
[__] old why is it such a big
deal oh because they're too old too old
Joe Biden's only a couple months older
than [__] Donald Trump and he can
ride a bike I don't know if that makes a
difference to you or
not but Donald Trump is even putting out
videos of him golfing and acting like he
and seriously they're saying he's the
most athletic president
ever and you should see this gulf swing
you should see that [__] that
cheeseburger gut get in the way of his
golf swing it is the shittiest golf
swing I've ever seen in my
life Joe Biden can ride a bike I can't
even ride a
bike I'm I'm 40 I can't write I mean I I
could attempt it it wouldn't look very
good I've been on a bike in a long
time but Jo can ride a goddamn bike and
we're worried about him being too old
come on people [__] out of here Donald
Trump's only a few months younger than
Donald Trump he's old too and he's too
old if Joe Biden's too old [__] out of
here now what the polls that they're
freaking out about is that oh my God 60
some percent of people think Joe Biden's
old yes because he [__] is old what
what the hell is the deal people in
their 20s okay all right just bear with
me here this is some [__] wild logic
it's going to blow your [__] mind
people in their early 20s think people
in their late 70s and early 80s are old
that's how it [__] works how don't
you know this what the [__] are you
worried about they're not gonna be
basing their election based on age folks
they're not they're not electing someone
based on how old they are in this next
election because the two guys that are
going to be one Republican one Democrat
they're months apart in age and one of
them can write a bik and the other one
can barely pick up a cheeseburger to
devour it so okay yeah I'm I'm over the
old stuff and the media is a bunch of
[__] the other [__] thing they're
talking about oh my God is Putin's
little puppet Jill Stein this [__]
this Russian
asset yeah Jill Stein's gonna run on the
green party ticket again oh my god well
she got a half a percent in
2016 she got a half a percent in 2016
hey dummy hey dummy Donald Trump was
running against someone different in
2016 he ran against Donald Trump in the
last election 2020 use those numbers you
[__]
fools if you're going to use election
numbers and poll numbers go to 2020 the
last presidential election where Joe
Biden and Donald Trump faced off and
we're gonna have a double header here
why wouldn't you use those numbers why
the [__] are you talking about Jill
Stein in 2016 and by the way if you're
talking about Jill Stein in 2016 how
about you talk about the trip she made
to Russia and sat at the table with the
Russian Nazis Mike Flynn yeah Mike Flynn
sitting at the [__] table and
Putin sitting at the [__] table with
Jill Stein folks this ain't like this
ain't like Jill Stein's talking about
Russian talking points Mike Flynn's
sitting right next to Putin and she's
sitting across the table from Mike Flynn
and
Putin and we're worried about messaging
this [__] stupid ass come on man [__]
man what the [__] are you talk and then
and then this Joe Mansion yesterday Joe
Mansions decided he's not GNA run for US
Senate which is oh it's a goddamn shame
ain't
it it's goddamn shame we won't have
mansion in the Senate anymore I'm gonna
be honest with you the the only downfall
to it is there's going to be a
republican in the West Virginia seat
yeah that's right I hate the break your
heart but some a Republican's gonna get
Joe mansion's seat that's the only good
thing about Joe Mansion being a senator
from West Virginia is our caucus in the
Senate gets one more even though it's
really not one
more some people are talking about this
might be the lead up to him running on
the No Labels ticket good we'll [__]
brand that [__] too why are we so afraid
in this country why the [__] is the
media afraid why is the pro democracy
Coalition afraid why why we should be
ready to fight like they fought in
Ohio like they fought in
Virginia like they fought in Kentucky
folks like we fought in 2022 when there
wasn't a red
wave come on let's get our [__] together
let's be excited about democracy let's
be excited about [__] stomping these
fascist
ass back where they came from let's do
this [__] this [__] we don't need to get
discouraged we don't need to be
pessimistic about this [__] Joe Mansion
[__] no labels [__] Jill Stein and [__]
RFK Jr as you want to know the honest
truth [__] that [__] don't worry about
them let's get the narrative straight
let's get let's get it going and let's
start winning this [__] election
there's going to be plenty of [__] to
pin on these dumb son of a
[__] the best they got the best they
got against us is economy bad and oh
there's Israel that's the best they got
folks the best they got unemployment's
at record
lows the stock markets through the roof
inflation is going the the direction
that we need it to go
backwards Joe Biden is for the American
worker not only did the did the
writers win their strike the UAW UPS but
now sag won their strike it's over labor
is winning in this country because the
president of the United States is
backing the American worker and the
American working
class not [__] Millionaires and
billionaires he don't give a [__] about
them he knows what his legacy needs to
be come on folks we can't get excited
about
this we can't brand Trump just as old as
as Biden come on it's [__]
ridiculous and we can't make sure that
we stomp out this idea that Jill Stein
who was sitting at the table with Putin
and Mike Flynn that [__] traitor Hey
listen I took a [__] this morning oh
man and it smell like a [__] traitor
so I named it Mike Flynn that's what I
named the [__] that I took this morning
Mike Flynn that's how much I think about
that piece of [__] that [__] traitor
that's right Mike I call you a [__]
traitor you domestic terrorist piece of
[__] you're [__] Putin's puppet
[__] come at
me him and his stupid [__] son and
his stupid [__] uh uh Reawakening
apparatus okay Q [__] out of here with
this nonsense bring it at bring it at me
white Christian nationalist let's do it
but Jill Stein sitting at the table with
him Joe mansion's gonna give up his
United state senate seat to run on on a
No Labels ticket who is barely going to
be in on ballots in
States RFK it's questionable whether
he's even going to get on ballots and
we're terrified of this stuff folks a
lot of Maga antia crazies are GNA go
right in RFK
Jr we need to stop this [__] we need to
get real real about democracy and the
way that you get real with democracy is
come here every every single [__]
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button it's free to subscribe here on
YouTube it's also free to follow us on
Twitch
twitch.tv thony Michaels go over there
if you have your Amazon Prime account
tied to your Twitch account don't forget
to renew your subscription and follow us
on Facebook you can watch live over
there on Facebook at the Tony Michaels
and you can follow our new group on
Facebook God we're having a lot of fun
in that group I think's like over 400
it's ticking up to 500 I bet we have a
thousand people by the end of the
weekend in this new group on Facebook so
if you got a Facebook account or you're
on Facebook go look for that group it's
called trumps full of [__] you'll find
it all over my page just go to at D Tony
Michaels on Facebook and you'll find
that some [__] and don't forget to
follow the Discord where the chat never
stops oh baby oh baby does the chat
never stop in Discord there's a lot of
cool stuff going on in Discord let me
tell you about a few things but I'm
going to put the um the link in the all
right in the chat here boom there's the
Discord make sure you go over there and
you check out the book club that's right
we're having a book club over on the
Discord the ver book is the obstacle is
the way by Ryan holiday the obstacle is
the way by Ryan holiday and we're also
listening to Rachel mat's audio book I
was actually in the room one day when
they were doing the Rachel M book so
they listen to it and then they have a
discussion afterwards so go check that
out also this weekend um this is a very
popular piece of merch even my dog hates
Ted even my dog hates Ted Cruz I'm going
to get the cat merch out I promise I
promise I promise we're going to get the
cat merch out we're going to have coffee
mugs we're goingon to have T-shirts uh
we're gonna get all kinds of stuff and I
think we're gonna have new names on here
too not just teed Cruz we're gonna go
after some other on Tech Cruz is easy to
hate though right I mean who who who
doesn't hate Ted Cruz and whose dog or
cat doesn't hate Ted Cruz I mean I think
my dog hates Ted Cruz more than I hate
Ted Cruz and I [__] despise T Cruz
[__] that guy you know what I
mean I want all O say thank you to
everyone who is still ordering the
tattoo merch is amazing how much how
much you guys like this design so much
so that we posted it everywhere we put
it as some of our avatars and on all of
our messaging you guys love this art
this machine kills fascist on the on the
tattoo that's right I'm gonna get this
tattooed on my arm right here it's gonna
be right here and the reason why I'm
getting it right here is so that way you
guys can see it literally I'm gonna put
it right here so you guys can see it
it's GNA be a microphone that's gonna
say this machine can fascism with the
with the Roses it won't look exactly
like the merch but it's inspired so you
can own a piece of merch that is
inspired by the tattoo that will go on
my arm in January not only that the
tattoo merch helps support the show and
helps support the tattoo because tattoos
aren't free and I got a great artist
I've had a great artist to do this and
what we're g to do I'm gonna take
pictures and videos and send you guys
that stuff because I'm I'm super excited
about this this will be my very first
tattoo I I my very first one that I'm
getting and we're going to do a whole
thing there's going to be Statue of
Liberty um there's going to be some
other stuff on my arm um from my
Heritage uh so a lot of that stuff will
be on on my arm to tell the story about
me um so I'm very excited about this
tattoo but the the tattoo merch here's
the another image of the hoodie I know
hoodies are really popular because it's
getting cold outside baby it's cold out
is it too early for Christmas
music so here it is we have James in the
chat James jarmelo has a birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
James I'm happy to have you here and I'm
happy to have all of you here on this
Friday you know what it means bonee head
of the week we'll have Gabe Sanchez with
us doing bonehead in the second hour but
don't go anywhere right now because
we're gonna show you some clips of this
fentol story and [__] and I'm going to
show you clips of Ronda santis saying we
need to execute these manga domestic for
Senate fentel don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what what you would do
you'd reach out and give that true
American a hand now here's your chance
for only $50 a day you can help us help
those true Americans recover from
Biden's socialist reign of terror these
are those Trump supporters and this is
that moment send your donation via venmo
to the real president Donald J Trump
it's only $50 a day recurring and it
means you'll get these Trump supporters
the critical help they so desperately
need to survive under this false regime
please donate now because those Trump
supporters you just saw can't wait
another
moment [__] them [__] them [__] them
[__] them [__] them [__] them we're back
to the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show oh we
have shares in the chat and he's being a
bigot of course hey Chez what kind of
envelopes do you
own your where's your mail station at
you got a mailbox in your neighborhood I
don't know I'm just check I'm just
asking questions I'm just [__] asking
questions here I'm just what do you want
from me I'm just answering questions
Shan says in the chat we need to ban all
transgender related content oh so like
freedom of speech you want to BR you
want to oh my God you hear this shance
is against Freedom oh [__] he's against
Freedom son of a [__] he's a fascist
holy [__] I couldn't have seen that I
did not see that coming Chaz you want to
ban all transgender why would you type
that in the chat who the [__] was
talking about
transgender who was talking about
transgender
shance it was it just you were you the
one focused on people's genitalia in the
chat out of nowhere that's kind of weird
maybe you and your online accountability
partner need to check in with each other
oh shz I love having you here my friend
God damn it's so easy when you're
here it is so easy when you're here I
don't know maybe you can help me with
this shz I'm trying to see if you know
this guy um this looks like we've got an
image here possibly of this uh mailbox
Bandit this fentanyl Fain um that
they're searching for I'm not sure
exactly um
you ever seen Sonic the Hench hog
Chez is this this has got to be one of
the shart Army sending a letter here
isin't it oh my
God oh my God it's Friday and it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be fun Friday I'm not
[__] you oh
man baby oh [__] what what are we what
are we doing here shz with this Shar
Army huh what what are you doing over
there is is this one of your is this one
of your one of your
guys I'm just asking questions I want
you to identify if this is a member of
the shart Army and I also want to know
where your closest mailbox
is I really want to know these are
questions we can
ask no you don't he says he stands for
Freedom what Shaz you stand for
Freedom oh [__] that's great you're like
I don't want people to even be be what
they want to be and I don't want them to
look at what they want to look at but
I'm For Freedom oh I'm For Freedom hey
Shaz you [__] idiot I actually give
you the freedom to come in here and say
crazy [__] in the chat you know what
that's called that's called that's
called Liberty I give you the Liberty to
come here and say dumb [__] in the chat
one reason why is because I love to pull
you up and beat the [__] out of you and
it's [__] fun and the audience loves
it they love it because you're such a
[__] it's fantastic because you have no
clue what's going on you have not a
[__] clue it's it's great content it
really is and I'd hate to give away the
game here because the audience is in on
it but you stand for Freedom get the
[__] out of here man you stand for
Freedom like Ronda santis doesn't wear
high heels get the [__] out of here
speaking of Ronda santis wearing high he
chz I don't want to make fun of Rhonda
Santos I really don't I I know I know
you get upset and it makes you feel
really hurt I when I make fun of Ronda
STIs godamn but look look here I want to
show you Ron's getting really good at
walking in those high heels he really is
he's getting fantastic at it I'm gonna
show you a video here of Ron going down
the
runway uh and I'm I'm assuming this is
Ronda Santa drag here I don't know let's
take a look here it is yeah there's Ron
look at Ron walking in them high heels
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hang on hang on hang on pause it pause
it pause it pause it that ain't Ronda
Sanz this person walks way too good in
high heels look I don't I don't want to
make fun of Ron I can't I can't make fun
of Ron because Shaz will get upset and
The Shard Army start crying The Shard
Army snowflakes will be really really
mad at me if I make fun of Ronda santis
this is not Ronda santis this person
walks way too good in these
heels oh I I see this this Kimberly guil
foil oh I
see yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah shake it shake it what does this
have to do with politics by the way what
the [__] does this have to do with
elections do you see why I say we're at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life look at this [__] Runway [__]
here I'm gonna I'm gonna I don't want to
hear the music but I'm GNA I'm going to
rewind it look at this she has to walk
all the way down this [__] Runway
right
what the [__] what the [__] are they
doing it's it's almost like this is a
trumpster fire show right this is weird
stuff isn't it never in my life have I
seen this kind of [__]
in
in in politics before this is weird
stuff I mean all she needs to do is take
off her clothes and put a poll and I'm
not saying that's not a thing that
should happen whatever you want to do if
you want to run a campaign where you got
strippers at your campaign event hey I'm
all for it whatever you want to do I
mean Shad here would love to go to a
campaign event where they had where they
had drag queens I mean he loves Ronda
santis he loves Ronda santis I mean look
he even says Ronda santz wears high heel
cowboy boots he does he does JZ he wears
high heel cowboy boots he wears Trump
drag he's in drag he put he wears he
wears the makeup he does his hair with a
lot of hairspray he wears heels he
probably wears a a a shape shifter you
know a waist
shifter Ronda santz does I'm just saying
he really likes makeup he really likes
high heel boots I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with it I actually think
that Ronda santz has the right Shaz to
dress up in Drag and it's and it he has
the right to walk as well as Kimberly
gilfoil does and heels I mean he doesn't
have the ability but he has the
right maybe maybe that's what he should
do maybe he should contact Eric do some
coke with Eric and Kimberly and Kimberly
can show him how to walk in a pair high
heels because everyone was making fun of
Kimberly gilfoil for this video but I
said at least she knows how to walk in a
pair of high heels unlike Ronda santz so
that was me not making fun of Ronda
santz Shez I'm really
sorry oh speaking of Rhonda
santis remember what he said about
fentol and anyone who has fentol
oh fentol fentol fentol let's hear what
Ron says about fentol we're declaring it
a National Emergency on day one I'm
sending military to the Border I'm Stop
The Invasion C I am going to deport
people who came illegally even going to
build the border wall and have Mexico
pay for it Like Donald Trump promised
how you
gon oh [__] Ron we've been through this
man you can't make Mexico pay for the
wall where the [__] were you man
where were you for four goddamn years
they tried this [__] it didn't work okay
well go ahead what else you going to do
that ain't going to happen gonna do it
yeah Mexico's not going to Fork over
money we're GNA impose fees on the
remittances that foreign workers foreign
countries oh oh so Mexico isn't actually
gonna pay for it she's like yeah
Mexico's gonna pay for it but they're
not gonna pay for it sh has don't you
see how the guy you support is a [__]
idiot here let me let me show you again
now I'm going to get to the part where
he's going to execute people people
without due process of law you know like
freedom and [__] chz like Freedom you
know the you know rights and [__] like
your right to be you know innocent till
proven guilty that kind of [__] but
listen to what he says about paying for
the wall and then not paying for the
wall listen wall and have Mexico pay for
it like and I Mexico pay for it Like
Donald Trump promised how you yeah he's
gonna have Mexico pay for it Chaz you
hear that you hear that Chaz yeah get
fired up because Mexico's going to pay
for a wall but going to do it yeah
Mexico is not going to Fork over
money
what sh you are such a dumbs some [__]
you know that God this is your guy this
is your guy this is your guy that's
Gonna Save Our
Country you're such a stupid [__] you
and anyone else who likes Donald Trump
and Ronda santis
anyone oh my God I'm sorry that I'm so
happy this morning I'm still happy about
this week this week has been fantastic
it's been a fantastic
week it really has I mean think about
think about the Fantastic week we've
had oh we got images of Ronda santis
apparently here um at the intersection
of WrestleMania and real life hang on
we'll get back to the video here is an
image thank you rat for the U the image
here wait is this Ron is this is this
Ron it looks like Ron and Ron drag here
this is Ronda santis drag um with the
makeup on I is he in or is Ron in
Kimberly guilfoil which is it R is Ron
in in in in desanta drag or is he in
Kimberly drag here which which one I
don't I can't figure this out I'm not
sure what we got here this seems uh I
don't know what do you think oh okay
okay all right that makes sense that
makes sense it's uh it's it's Kimberly
drag Ron and Kimberly drag okay well
let's go back to the clip let's see if
we can find out exactly thank thank you
R thanks for all the work you're doing
there in the lab getting us all these
great images out there I mean how else
would we know who the who the shart Army
terrorists are that are putting letters
in mailboxes here's here's Ronda santis
Moore here's shaz's Idol who who wears
who's in drag on stage here he is let's
let's listen to what he wants to do at
people at the border Morgan imposed fees
on the remittances that foreign workers
send to foreign countries we'll raise
billions of dollars I'll build a wall
but we are going to designate the
cartels to be foreign terrorist
organizations or something similar to
that and we're going to authorize the
use of deadly force oh do you hear that
do you hear that the cartels are sending
Maga fentol did you hear that they're
terrorist the the cartel terrorist are
sending maganga terrorist fentel so they
can send to our election offices so they
can intimidate our election our election
officials holy [__] did you see how he
put that two to two together Rhonda
santis here is admitting that manga is
working with the with the cartel listen
again listen again here listen to how he
explains foreign workers send to foreign
countries we'll raise billions of
dollars I'll build a wall but we are
going to designate the cartels to be
foreign terrorist organizations or okay
foreign terrorists who work with the
domestic terrorist organizations like
The Shard Army who are putting letters
in the mail with fentol on it that the
cartel is bringing over across the
border via probably shart arm
soldiers I mean I'm not going to lie
it's US citizens who bring fentol
through Port of ventry Ronda Sanz
doesn't know that well he knows that
he's just lying to Shaz and The Shard
Army he's got them confused like when he
gets him confused about the wall he's
like yeah I'm gonna make Mexico pay for
the wall just like Donald Trump said he
would but Mexico's not actually gonna
pay for the wall what okay all right
we'll keep going something similar to
that and of deadly force we're going to
have maritime operations to interdict
precursor chemicals going into Mexico
but I'll tell you this someone in the
drug cartels sneaking fencing all across
the border when I'm present that's going
to be the last thing they do we're gonna
shoot him stone cold
dead you hear that chz you hear that
he's totally not for Freedom he's
totally not for due process of law chz
listen buddy I I know I know you like
Ronda santis because you're a fascist
and because you got little secrets on
your cell phone that you don't want
anyone to know that's why you want to
get in the chat and talk about
transgender content or some [__] no one
was saying anything about transgender
people man whoa that's wild stuff we
know we know what's we know what's
lurking around on your little electronic
devices probably but Ronda santis when
he finds out when he when he puts the
Christian app on your phone to tell on
you about the porn you're watching guess
what he's going to shoot you Cold Stone
dead because he doesn't believe in the
due process of law he do believe
Freedom matter of fact he probably
should agree that when we find this
shart Army terrorist that is mailing
mailing letters all over the country to
try to poison people Ronda santis
probably wants to shoot them stone cold
dead I mean he won't act that way
because it's definitely GNA be a manga
terrorist
definitely oh wait wait wait wait we
have an updated image here of
and this makes way more sense now that
the AI has gotten this correct now it
now
it it's a meatball and Kimberly Gil foil
drag here at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life godd damn this
is a good one I'm not gonna lie rant
this is is this real or is this AI rant
which is this is this real or is it
AI
you got new Tunes you got new Tunes
goddamn yeah they're great new Tunes
everyone was getting tired of the old
Tunes so you you obviously made new
Tunes that's
fantastic well I know I know I know I
know I probably played the tune way too
much but I liked the tune I like the is
it real or is it AI tune and I love your
images here because this one looks real
I'm not going to lie it looks like a
meatball and drag which is 100% Ronda
santis and what the audience shouldn't
do is go to Discord and find this image
and post it all over the
Internet it's definitely not what they
should do thank you red for your
contribution to society today of getting
AI to find this this image yeah yeah all
right all right well let's let's move on
to um more more clips about this this
fentanyl [__] other than Ronda
santis wanting to actually execute these
things execute the shart Army for doing
this let's go to report I think this is
a CBS News has this here uh brand
ranburger also did a press conference
but what let's watch CBS News here real
quick and see what their report is on
the breaking news of the FBI uh under
uncovering who did this breaking news in
a series of potentially deadly and
targeted attacks on Election workers
across the country the FBI and
investigators from the US Postal Service
are looking into more than a dozen
letters some containing fenel that were
sent to election offices in at least
five states now workers in some of those
offices were processing ballots from
Tuesday's election and in some cases the
buildings were evacuated interrupting
the counting of votes since 2020 there's
been a rise in threats harassment and
intimidation of election officials cbs's
Jeff pay has the latest on the investig
ation he'll start us off tonight from
right here in Washington with new
reporting good evening Jeff Nora tonight
FBI agents and postal inspectors are
racing to figure out who is Behind These
threats those letters were just dropped
in the mail by someone who seems to be
bent on terrorizing election workers I
wonder what political affiliation that
could be H terrorizing election work I
want is there's got to be an instance in
recent history where election workers
were terrorized and they sued someone
who was supporting Donald Trump maybe
even criminally convicted in the same
goddamn State H I wonder if uh I wonder
if Ruby Freeman and sheay Moss would
have anything to say about this you
realize you realize that that these
terrorists are sending to Georgia
folks Shay mosson and Ruby Freeman sued
the [__] out of Rudy
Giuliani one and the reason why is
because they were getting the Maga shart
Army to terrorize
them with
lies why do you think they're mailing
this [__] to Brad ranus smus
panburger huh you think this is just a
[__] coincidence [__] out of here
with that nonsense
this isn't a
coincidence one of these things are like
the
other that's what's happening here and
they're going to find this [__] but
let's let's listen to a little more in
this
report so this is very very serious and
we take it that way a source familiar
with the investigation tells CBS News
there are more than a dozen letters
being investigated addressed to election
offic offes in Washington state Oregon
California Nevada and Georgia that okay
look at this
map look at this
Matt I would say I would say that
they're looking for some scumbag in
these states over here that decided that
it was a good idea because he Trump's
got really big enemies over
here that what it looks like to you I
don't know that's just my actually I'm
looking at here I mean I'm no [__]
FBI agent right I'm no [__] FBI agent
I'm not but when I look at this map of
where these letters are being mailed I'm
like Yep this [__] is on this
side of the
country and they're shipping a letter
here I don't know maybe I'm out of my
mind right this is what I do though I
look at something at first glance this
is the first time I seen this clip folks
I picked out a bunch of Clips we were in
The Producers corner I was a little late
this morning I forgot it was Friday but
I was a little late to the producers
Corner this morning but I was there they
were there they were there the whole
hour and they were talking about great
stuff and we brought up this fentanyl
thing and that's how we came to this
would be the lead story because it is a
lead story it's MAA terrorists trying to
kill election
workers they're trying to kill election
workers because they're counting
ballots fasy fasy you think
huh fascists kill election workers
that's what fascists
do when you're on the side of people who
are trying to kill election workers and
intimidate election workers you're a
fascist I hate to break it to you but
when I look at this map this is the
first time I've seen this
clip when I look at this map here my
first instinct is it not yours my first
instinct is is this some [__] is on
this side of the country in one of these
states or are adjacent to these
states and this some [__] and it's
definitely a some [__] I say he because
it's a he 100% it's a [__] him hey
hey
Shaz it's one of them it's one of them
humans with a
Wier if you want to talk about gender
and Jay Shaz there you go there's your
first opportunity to get in the chat and
be a bigot I just brought up gender it's
definitely a [__]
H and he's
white and he's got a name like
Bubba right or
Fred like that stupid son [__] got
killed by the FBI because they came to
take his [__] weapons because he was
out of his mind he was going to try to
kill kill Joe Biden he was threatening
to kill the president you remember that
a few months
ago had to kill that some
[__]
but I look at this map and I'm like yeah
this seems like he's got a whoever's
mailing these letters got a beef on this
side of the country and then they're
like yeah Trump they hate Trump in
Georgia so I'll send a letter over here
that's what I'm getting from it I don't
know maybe I'm outside my [__] mind I
doubt it but let's continue may have
been mailed from the Pacific Northwest
and
I I swear I didn't see this clip I swear
I didn't see this clip did you just hear
that may have been May from the Pacific
Northwest uh do you know do you know why
do you know why I'm always [__] dead
on do you know why because you just try
to get to the lowest common denominator
and think how a right-winger would think
right you just try to be as dumb as dog
[__] just like okay what is the worst
idea and then what's a worser idea and
then go one step further and that is
where Maga starts to go downhill okay
like that's why I'm always on is because
I just try to put my mind where the [__]
their mind would be yeah I know it's
difficult it's it's a
stretch but it's from the Pacific
Northwest and of course I didn't again I
didn't watch the clip and I stopped the
clip when the you see me there's
evidence I stopped the clip there and
then I gave you my idea I didn't watch
this I swear to you that may have been
mailed from the Pacific Northwest
initial tests show that some of the
letters contain Trace Amounts of fenel
but more definitive tests are ongoing in
Georgia where election officials have
been targeted since 2020 the secretary
of state says the threat hang on hang on
um Robin here
on on Twitch says the m whisper easy
easy on the nicknames here good Lord
you're going to piss people off they
already call me the wrestling ball the
left and that really gets people mad and
upset um the manga
Whisperer that'll really piss them off
okay let's keep going that is personal
you know some people like to call
fentanyl a drug but it's actually poison
it'll kill you Olden County has been the
recipient of numer okay I I I wanna I
wanna I want to stop Brad RIS path
Matthis Burger there listen dude most
drugs in in in a certain dose is [__]
poison it can kill you I don't know if
you know that dummy why the I can't
believe that they don't like this guy
Brad ranburger is a [__] [__] he is
a
bonehead he is a Christian
conservative they should love this
[__] [__] and he says stupid
[__] like this listen listen to what he
says here this is really stupid stuff
this is dumb listen is personal you know
some people like to call fentanyl a drug
it is a drug but it's actually poison
yeah in certain do doses it it can kill
you what the [__] what are you talking
about that's like the stupid [__] they
say like oh man if if you get within 100
feet of fit and all you're dead you're
dead no what are you talking about
the F listen fentanyl is a very very
very very [__] potent
drug and the [__] that they that they
bring in this country to [__] pimp on
the streets is even more potent and more
dangerous yeah it's [__] dangerous
it's
drugs hello think McFly think why do you
think it t why do you think there's more
regulations to go buy [__] psea fed
than a goddamn
gun which is ridiculous when you think
about it right it's really [__] dumb
you're like really I got to give you my
[__] phone number my address my
social security number you want my blood
type and you want my school records to
buy Puda
fed yeah I think I'll go down to the gun
shop and buy a gun and just blow my
brains out geez [__] I mean that's
way easier to get a gun than to buy suda
fed I'm [__] I'm [__] I need suda
fed dying
here but they don't do that because oh
you can make drugs out of it it's
[__] so dumb and this is dumb why
again this is the [__] I'm talking about
when I say the narrative needs to get
out there fast because this kind of [__]
even the guy that's getting fentanyl
sent to him is saying stupid [__] know
some people like to call fentanyl a drug
it is a drug but it's actually poison
it'll kill youon county has been the re
ion of numerous election related threats
over the last several years it's the
county where former president Trump has
been indicted along with 18 others in
connection with an alleged racketeering
case I wonder who could have sent I
wonder I wonder what the beef could be
of the guy from the Pacific Northwest
the shart Army
soldier I wonder what it could be that
they sent it to that office in Georgia I
wonder what I wonder what it could be
it's almost like there's something going
on down there [__] Gabe Sterling a
Georgia elections official says the
fental LA letters are domestic terrorism
they are domestic terrorism you remember
this guy this guy is the guy that came
out in front of a microphone in 2020 in
December 2020 was telling Donald Trump
to shut the [__] up you remember that he
was a deput deputy secretary of state
and he came out and he said hey
[__] stop talking your [__] or
you're going to get people killed and he
did Donald Trump got Ashley babbit
killed and got a bunch of cops killed on
January 6 that's what Donald Trump did
and this guy's right now this guy's a
[__] bux don't again don't hero these
people like Brad ratburger and this
[__] this Gabe what's his name Gabe
something don't be [__] hero Rising
these
people they're [__] they're [__]
Republicans don't be making Heroes out
of these people just because they say
the truth Gabe Sterling I think his name
is let's listen can't think of every
single threat so this now raises it on
our radar to some we can train for and
planned for but it's also another
stressor for elections officials that
are under tremendous pressure already
the dangerous letters come as election
officials around the country are under
threat how has the threat environment
changed toward election workers post the
2020 election it's been fairly
consistently High threat environment
since the 2020 election over three years
ago now we've seen abuse threats and
harassment of election
officials wonder who could it be H I
don't know maybe we should check the
mailboxes of the shirt Army in the
Pacific
Northwest yeah I think shaz's left
people are asking on Facebook if shaz's
left are you guys coming over to
Facebook just to [__] with him don't do
that that's
mean it's [__] mean it's mean I'm
look I'm not supposed to be making fun
of Ronda santz and I put up one image
one image that we find on the internet
of Ronda santis the meatball dressed in
Kimberly guilfoil
drag and he leaves what a what a [__]
snowflake but yeah I think he left he
left so sad now I can't pull his
comments up all right let's move on to
more um fent all talk actually you know
what I should we go to the uh the Jill
Stein is a Russian anet
talk maybe we can do that uh boy let's
see um I think I got one other report
here that I want to show of this
um uh black dragon here says
fentanyl in very small doses works
wonders for pain that's actually what
fentanyl is and that's how it's
developed now once you get the the you
know once you let the cat out of the bag
for these drugs people are going to
produce it especially in foreign
countries and try to get the the
[__] ones brought into this country
right it's just it's what's going to
happen uh and I I know there's probably
sever audience members who've lost the
loved ones that have F fall to addiction
of
venol I'm sure there are um just because
I I know a lot of our audience lives in
some of these areas where Republicans
won't do [__] about fent all they won't
do [__] about helping people who have
these
addictions to opioids and
like um I'm
I'm I'm sorry uh I gotta go to another
comment here Harry Poppin says Glenn
kersner says you're full of
[__] did he say that did he really say
that I mean I'd love to see a clip of
that Harry I'd love to see a clip of
Glenn is it but my question is is it
Glenn number one Glenn number two or
Glenn number three let me show you the
the difference here now this here this
is Glenn number one okay here's Glenn
number one
Harry this is Glenn number one so was it
this Glenn
or was it Glenn number two the one that
I you know this is who I'm assuming
Glenn number two is the one who said it
and someone was saying yesterday and a
lot of people um Christa on Facebook
says is it Glenn or is it Glenn you're
right I don't know I don't know if
there's two ins or one in maybe there's
Glenn two and then Glen two I don't know
I mean this here is Glenn two that's on
the screen this is Glenn two that's on
the
screen this is not AI this is real I
swear to you this is real you can see
the NBC News logo in the back background
Glen kersner is is legit he's a former
United States prosecutor the guy's an
attorney and he's a MSM NBC contributor
legal contributor so you know he's not
full of
[__] you know what's funny about this oh
my God people in the comments yesterday
and I got I gotta say it felt like to me
that there was one person that was
really upset about the [__] I said about
Glenn yesterday and you came to the
YouTube page under a bunch of different
sock
accounts and you just kept posting stuff
about how I'm wrong about the 14th
Amendment and that the the Minnesota
Supreme Court didn't say that that you
can't 14th him yeah yeah they did no it
was a primary ballot yeah it's a primary
ballot but it's a private party but the
state sanctions it they still have even
though the Republican party is running
the election the state still has to
count the votes this is so stupid they
use State
money you're not you're not you're not
understanding what I'm
saying obviously the problem is is that
you want to use the 14th Amendment the
way that John Eastman wanted to use the
Constitution to send the [__] votes
back to the states do you follow me on
that I'm not saying Glen to here is
advocating for a coup that is not what
I'm saying what I'm saying is the theory
that you're trying to
use the theory that you're trying to use
is this of the Constitution is the same
way that they try to use the
Constitution for Mike Pence to use a
power that he didn't have because you're
using it and an interpretation of it
that is not the actual
interpretation you're just making [__]
up because you want this guy to be right
and I know a lot of people came to
comments like oh you're attacking Glenn
and he's not the only one saying this
yeah I know that hell I'm not the only
one saying what I'm saying you know the
funny part though is I've never changed
my [__] views on
this you can go back all the way to when
Glenn two this is Glenn two I want to be
clear on this this is not Glenn
one be very clear on this when Glenn 2
released his video where he was calling
for the 14th Amendment to be used to
keep Donald Trump off the ballot I
immediately that day said that's a bunch
of
[__] and I have stuck to my idea
that it's a bunch of
[__] and it's and it's not that it's
not possible folks 14th Amendment we've
used it several times in this
country everyone keeps keeps sending
comments that yeah it's him yeah number
two is him I don't wondering why why
couldn't he get number one or just Glenn
Kushner or the real Glenn Kushner right
he had to settle on number
two really that's what you had to settle
on was number two this is wild oh we
have we have a oh man we have a Glenn
news update apparently here um what's
the Glen news update uh oh I better
get is this Glenn number four I don't
know maybe this is Glenn number four
Glenn number four has h
oh
[__] oh this is just someone reporting
on the Glenn update is it is did we find
number one and number
two did we find
that oh boy and I I know I know that you
guys like Glenn I understand and you
like his commentary because you know
Justice matters so do social media
handles I would
say social media handles matter too but
Justice does matter but
folks I want to tell you about this 14th
thing and I know there's a lot of people
in the comments saying Tony read 14
section three I have I've read it I've
read 14th Amendment section three yes
it's pretty clear and I don't know
exactly what you're saying here on
Facebook Michelle which I I again I
welcome descent I want you guys to
descent Becky says I think you're wrong
Tony or I think you're mistaken I could
be wrong I could be mistaken I'm
not I'm not wrong about it undermining
our democracy
folks either way this is going to go to
the Supreme
Court it's going to go to the Supreme
Court and it's going to be horrible no
matter what the
decision no matter what the decision is
going to undermine our
democracy the one thing we should not be
doing in our liberal
democracy is using some wild legal
theory about our constitution to keep
one person away from an office that's
wild
stuff that's wildly and it smells fashy
it smells really fasy once he's
convicted I'm all for it he's now
convicted he no longer he no longer is
afforded the right to be innocent until
proven guilty once he's proven guilty
fol folks you are no longer afforded
that right in the court of law and he
can be 14th cuz the language in the 14th
section three is very
clear it is very clear on that he's not
convicted yet and I know you want him to
be I want him to be I think he's going
to be convicted on several of these
felony charges but we're not there
yet and if you want to live in a steeped
reality of Truth then get with the truth
and the truth is he's not convicted yet
and he won't be convicted in time to
take him off a
ballot now it is possible under the law
of my interpretation and I'm no lawyer
you don't have to be a lawyer to look at
the law and interpret it by the way just
go ask [__] Tom
Finton that [__]
bonehead under law even if he's afforded
the right to get on the the ballot they
can 14th him even after they print
ballots yes they can do that they can do
that hell they could forth him and
remove him from
office after he's convicted as far as
the 14th Amendment is
concerned but it's going to damage
democracy if we do it
before
folks cuz when when MAA says if they can
come after him they can come after you
you know that backwards ass thinking
right because it's the opposite
direction if the feds can come after
you and come get you they should be able
to go after the most powerful person in
in in the maganga country right that's
the way it should
be but if we use the law to go after him
they can come after us you get it right
you understand what I'm saying right you
understand what I'm saying that Glenn
isn't stupid Glenn doesn't know it's not
that he doesn't know what he's talking
about it's not that Glenn has some wild
idea from the Constitution that is just
absolutely out of
bounds what I'm saying is is it's a
waste of time to do this because it's
damaging our democracy it's undermining
the institution
of our liberal democracy
folks it undermines the entire
narrative it undermines it I don't care
what you say I don't care how many times
you type
it I don't care how much you like Glenn
I don't care how smart he is what his
experience is that he's a lawyer and I'm
not I don't give a [__] about any of
that none of that
matters none of that [__] matters to
narrative because you want to know the
honest truth about it the the reason why
I'm so hard on
Glenn is because I believe Glenn put
that video out to get views and
clicks now Glenn number two to be clear
I don't I don't want to
disparage Glenn number one let me let me
show you Glenn number one here's Glenn
number one I don't want to disparage
Glenn number
one Glen number two is the one who put
out the statement again I don't I don't
know the difference I hope we can get to
the bottom of this maybe Glenn number
two can come on the show and
clarify who he is but apparently someone
said he's very upset about what I'm
saying which is fine I want him to be
upset Regina says you're I'm making
trouble I'm not making trouble I would
never I would never do that oh that's
the other thing that's the other thing
Regina so that's that's I know you're
laughing
because a lot of people don't understand
that I'm goofing on Glenn I'm goofing on
him a bit and the reason why I'm goofing
on Glenn is because Glenn's a smart guy
Glenn actually really does know what
he's talking
about he does that's why I'm goofing on
him because he's [__] wrong about
this and he's not wrong about the 14
section three he's wrong because it
undermines democracy and it undermines
justice if you want to know the honest
[__]
truth what kind of justice is that that
they can prevent you from from
exercising your right to be on a ballot
I don't care if it's Trump or you what
what what [__] Justice matters if
they can keep you off a
ballot when you're not convicted of
something you aren't you supposed to be
innocent still proven guilty why don't
we have equal equal Equal justice under
the law then Glenn
huh there's plenty of [__] people in
this country that are stuffed away in
prisons for stupid [__] [__] stupid
[__] [__] mostly black men that's
that's who the two tier justice system
Targets in the first place is black men
I don't know if you [__] know
that I bet there's a lot of black dudes
that are sitting in prison for
nonviolent crimes for decades and
decades and decades that would like to
have a word about this that would love
to have a word about the 14th
Amendment I just want you I just want
you to have an opinion about something
have an equal opinion about another
thing that's
all and yeah Regina I am kind of making
trouble because a lot of people like oh
if you want Glenn on your show this is
no way to get Glenn is to goof on him
[__] it ain't [__] it ain't if Glenn
number two really found out that I was
pounding on him and beating on him and
questioning why he can secure Glenn at
Glenn kersner he had to go with Glenn
kersner too holy [__] he definitely
would come on the show and clarify it
I'm sure he would you know who else
would come on the show to clarify some
[__] you know who else would the guy
with the last name Sanchez hey it's the
second hour welcome buddy hey sorry I
was just I was wrapping up the video
yeah I got sidetracked with Glen number
two did you know this look I want to
show you something here I want to show
you this this is Glenn number two okay
we have confirmed this is Glenn number
two now I want show you a picture of
what we think is Glenn number one okay
this is Glenn number one we're not sure
Glenn kersner is and we're not sure who
Glenn kersner 3 is we're not really sure
we know we know this is what wait what's
going on I have no idea if you go look
at Glenn's handle it's Glenn kerser 2 I
don't know I have no idea I I'm trying
to figure out who number one is who
number two is I know I know the audience
hates when I when I knock on number two
and the reason why is because they think
he's right about the 14th Amendment and
here recently the the the Minnesota
Supreme Court said he's full of [__] and
not just him not Glenn but you know the
people who want to for Trump in general
right or before he's convicted of the
crimes that he definitely committed in
DC but but we have equal justice under
the law and you're supposed to be
innocent until proven guilty right and
and I've been explaining to audience
that we can't sacrifice that because
it's the same thing when Ma's like oh
you know what you know what if they can
do it to Trump then they can do it to me
which is backwards that's [__] that's
backwards right okay okay got it so what
you're saying is that you you don't
think I mean I mean in in I guess in the
same reasoning of like let's say George
Santos you wouldn't remove someone ex
from the position or the potential to
have position because they haven't
though I mean all signs lead to guilty
exactly right we have to follow the rule
of law and say you're innocent until
proven guilty godamn that's a good
analysis and you know what you know
what's funny about that you know what's
funny about that is that's actually what
the law says that's actually what is
that you're innocent until proven guilty
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is and
because it's a public contract that's
the other thing too because some people
like oh well he would be fired from his
job yeah but that that's a private
contract that's not a public contract
when you go U get on a ballot and
there's some laws that prevent felons
from being on ballots the presidential
ballot is not one of them it's not one
of them so literally even if Donald
Trump was a villain and he's convicted
of a crime that doesn't automatically
disqualify which is kind of crazy to
think about let's say that Donald Trump
you know let's say that all the stars
line up and Donald Trump is in prison
it's kind of crazy to be like oh yeah
you know what the guy that's behind a
jail cell right now now or the you know
Behind Bars can run for president now I
don't know how logistically that works
out if like there's some crazy outcome
where the person is elected like how
does that work I have no idea we've
never seen that before but then again
we've never had a president who has been
you know upwards of 91 felony counts
against him you know I mean this is a
crazy crazy world and timeline we're in
uh what a time to be alive it is quite a
time to be alive and it's quite a time I
don't know for Bon head of the week so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this bone head of the
week we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul goar and thanks to my new product
paron blanket I've got you covered paron
blanket specifically Works to make you
feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup hard
and blanket will protect you too Hardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100% made in the USA don't delay and get
your pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show you
know what time it is it's Friday Friday
Friday we got to have a game the guy
with the last name
Sanchez with
us bone
head game
s I'm wondering I think a lot of people
would really like to have themselves a
pardon blanket for Christmas I mean
paron yourself whenever possible you get
in trouble you didn't clean the dishes
you didn't do the chores right you maybe
in a fight whatever it might be maybe
you're in trouble at work at any point
just wrap yourself up in that pardon
blanket and you know that you are safe
now as soon as you take it off I don't
know what'll happen but once you keep it
on once you put it on and if you keep it
on many people are saying that you're
pardoned many people are saying that the
pardon blanket excuse me excuse me rude
I just there's there's so many different
manner isms to Trump like obviously the
small hands and everything he does his
little accordion but the fact whenever
somebody talks like excuse me excuse me
rude rude very rude okay mean very mean
lady okay let me
continue anytime someone says something
when he is talking he's like excuse me
excuse me rude rude as if anything
Donald Trump does isn't Rudee right
right the idea that this guy just exists
in reality everything he says and does
is rude so when he's like rude rude and
it's like are they is it rude they just
spoke oh man that audience is hating on
me the Glenn's the Tony sucks gab rocks
excuse me excuse me many people are
saying many people are saying gabes many
people many people are
saying thanks I didn't say say it many
people many people in my head thank
thanks for the um thanks thanks for the
comment I really appreciate it welcome
to excuse me excuse me this is bonehead
of the week okay right ion bonehead
maybe I maybe I'm the bonee head of many
people are shame do you think do you
think they would vote for me if we put
me on the it's possible I almost put
Tony on the bonehead last
night this is true it is true oh boy I
was late with the Bon head of week last
night people were W running about it oh
so I have a story for you oh yeah go
ahead so last night
uh last night does this involve your
online accountability partner because
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay
this is this is what I'll say we're
gonna play a game okay put a finger down
Edition all right okay put a finger down
if you've ever
gone uh or if you've ever driven to a
rehearsal or a practice for an event
that you're doing doing and you're
trying to find parking so you circle
around and around and around the block
hoping to find a parking space yeah and
then you roll up on a car where you see
from a distance they've got their tail
lights on and you say hey look wow they
must be about to leave so you roll up to
this blue
BMW you go side by side to the driver
window and you say hey hey hey are you
moving and then you realize oh well it's
night and it's a 10 window so maybe they
didn't see you so then you say oh oh
okay I'll roll down the window so you
roll down the window and then you go to
the driver's side when you say hey are
you are you leaving the space can I get
in here and you kind of make out this
body in the in the front seat and they
go and I'm not I'm not I'm not leaving
no you're not leaving you not like right
now like what are you doing and then
they wave
off but then as your eyes adjust to the
tinted window in the dark scene of the
night you realize there's a body
specifically a head that's moving up and
down oh and down hey I'm I'm getting
serviced yes is that what the uh so then
you realize you're like is that why
they're pumping the brakes is that why
they're pumping the brakes yeah they're
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
who look I was like oh my God I was like
man just turn the car off then no one
would ever have to and here's thing so I
go to rehearsal and I go in and I'm
talking to was like Hey so this is what
just happened and someone else on my
team was like wait was it the car that's
a block over because I did that very
same thing and I in my head I thought I
thought you were gonna say oh well the
taste is still in my
mouth God no no no what happened was
they were like oh I also was looking for
parking and I did the same thing and I
and I did a double take but I didn't
even I was like did I just see that no I
didn't just see what I thought I just
saw and the fact that you're telling me
the story now only confirms the fact
that that was happening and I was like
dude if you're going to do that don't do
it in an area where like everyone's
trying to find parking why or or or
don't or don't what listen don't keep
those don't keep the car on No One's
Gonna stop by if you have tail lights on
you're only drawing attention to you
what if they were listening to the radio
I mean what if there was like this
Rhythm thing that they needed or you
know I I don't know I mean I'm not going
to hate on them I was like look man if
you're going to do that don't leave your
car on and don't do it in an area
where you are only asking for people to
look for a space you know what make busy
area downtown LA very busy area you know
what make it even better instead of him
holding up a hand if he would to hel
hold up a tiny hand and
like no no no excuse me excuse me very
rude okay just keep just keep driving
okay okay just keep driving don't stop
don't oh maybe get it maybe get a maybe
get a closeup okay okay okay keep going
keep
going oh my I was like wow this is a I
was like that is a start to my
[Music]
night is this the new theme
music oh my god oh man Tony sucks Gabe
rocks excuse me very make a whole whole
segment out of that
probably I I think I think they thought
I was gonna be mad at that at that
comment tonyy sucks skab bronos maybe
maybe it was me in the car with the you
know since I suck wow that was a long
that was a long trip you took just for
that since I suck since I suck all right
speaking of sucking look at these look
at these suckers V Rami Kami FY FY ramen
noodles guy and then Roseanne Bar oh man
I thought she was I I didn't know she
was still alive she's still alive rosan
bar still alive she is still out there
the last last time I saw Roseanne Bar
she was doing a standup and and I say
this stand up special standup I put in
Big quotes here stand up Don
Jor Joe Biden and rosean Jo Biden it's
hilarious okay Best comedian ever to
exist Roseanne Bar
um but the last time I saw Rosanne bar
was when she did it was and it was uh
hosted and broadcasted by Fox news I
think it was on their like Fox Nation
their like they didn't put it on Fox
News it's it's on their digital shitty
service or whatever and so the only joke
I saw which I was like well this is
everything I need to know is the joke
she told was the joke that every
Republican says mag the Ted Cruz joke
yes it's the Ted Cruz joke they'll
attack pronouns and lgbtq and this and
that and the go-to joke is my pronouns
are kiss my ass and you're like that's
so funny it's like oh maybe the first
time you said it you're like oh okay but
every time after that when Ted Cruz says
it at every single event he goes to and
then Roseanne Bar who's supposed to be
this hilarious comedian I mean maybe
back in the day there was a moment where
she aligned with certain people on the
left but she has been gone Far
Over far over onto the right she is
delusional as we've
seen during that that magga Trump
is that why is so is it this this is the
video here um this is the the video here
where she where she's wearing a cowboy
hat I think is and she there's a couple
videos one she's doing a dance but the
one the one that she really is going
after some bull which I'm assuming is
Biden I don't know well let's listen
here and see what she has to I to uh get
my picture taken with President Trump
about a week ago there at Mara Lago you
know and this a different
one it was so exciting I could hardly
control myself I went in there and I
just uh I grabbed at him you know wh
what what I I'm gonna tell you this
sounds like Roseanne has been drinking a
bit I mean you know I mean when have you
met a republican who has gone and given
a speech at a trump rally I mean look
Rudy Giuliani Jr majusi he was [__]
plastered thankfully he never got into
office and then you've got I mean I'm
sure there's other people but then you
also got Roseanne Bar who like can
barely make it up to the mic so she's
like right here well you know what you
know what the problem is here sh I you
know I know what the problem is is that
Ronda santis forgot to mail the the pair
of high heel cowboy boots that's what it
was she's supposed to be dressed in the
santis drag here and she obvously didn't
get the boots that go along with the
drag that's probably what it is well
let's let's let's listen a little more
to
this literal
nonsense and uh he was so nice he just
kind of gently rearranged my arm so
nicely what I don't remember and
afterwards I thought oh my God I could
have got
shot the way I was grabbing at him with
the secret surface I was just like
a so she's talking about grabbing him by
the [__] I guess I don't know what I
don't know she's want to grab him by the
[__] and here here is love
you here's cut that sound cut that sound
love
you like I love you oh God but you know
what's funny about she's like I was
grabbing him like Mike Lindell grabs a
my pillow look at this right on
screen oh my God oh my God people are
par of themselves you cannot make this
stuff up oh my God you cannot write this
they do it themselves and you're like
and this is why comedy is dead you know
it's just like there are so many moments
where you see this and you're like I
could not have imagined that this would
have happened because
literally have not thought about rosean
bar for months the last time I thought
about her was when I put that pronoun
joke into a what was that that I'm going
to release in in a day or so
that was it have not seen her since and
now she has resurfaced and made
herself the bell of the
ball well here's here's the thing here's
the thing is because rosean bar used to
be [__] hilarious and I don't know if
people out there watch the show Roseanne
but when Roseanne was actually doing
that show she was doing the show from
the perspective of the average working
American who you know struggles
struggles with things like I don't know
inss meet affording groceries rent
losing their job trying to get ahead in
life it always feels like you're living
paycheck to paycheck that's what the
original show was about um but Roseanne
Bar really jumped the shark on that show
and she got super [__] Rich so
Roseanne Bar went from being the person
that she was talking about in her show
to being the person who steps on those
people's head and and if people don't
remember it's because she went on this
islamophobic right wasn't it
islamophobic well that was that was the
that was the reason why the the second
show the second time they tried to reair
the
show mean that's where I pulled by the
way that's where I pulled her image
because she has she's never been on
bonehead of the week and the image I
pulled for her bonehead was when she was
doing the interview and she's like I
didn't [__] know I didn't [__]
know what she
was that's the image from it yeah that's
great that's great but but no rosean bar
used to be funny and the reason why she
used to be funny is because she actually
had some grounding into like what
average Americans go through on a
day-to-day basis like she was able to
speak and punch up with her comedy yeah
right now she just doesn't have any kind
of sense of comedy and the reason why is
because Roseanne Bar became the person
who she was punching at um that's what
she's become she's become the person
that she was punching at where she she's
a celebrity Beyond celebrity and she's
wealthy Beyond her Wildest Dreams folks
like rosean bar has so much [__]
money she lives on she lives in Hawaii
right on a on like a is it some sort of
farm like a like a potato something like
I'll say this she does make some weird
videos on her YouTube channel which I've
weird well that's that's a
ni that's a nice way of putting it
that's a nice way of putting it weird
weird is a nice way of describing those
videos she's
aath they're they're deranged they're
unhinged I mean some of these videos she
it looks like she
is I mean before she like start
restarted or started up a new podcast or
whatever and has like come back into the
light of like public
appearance if you go to her YouTube page
there's a point where she's like in bed
eating and it's like I dude what kind of
state are you in right now like this
doesn't look like did you burn through
your money you don't seem to be in in a
state of like I'm doing
well and then it's like her son running
the YouTube channel and he's like oh man
we just made $1,000 on the YouTube
channel and you're like bro isn't she a
millionaire like why are we why are we
discussing making a thousand dollar over
a month for someone who has the money to
pay that 100x you know is this before or
after the speech here is this the I
don't know because I like I didn't watch
this I was watching the I was watching
oh
yeah
[Music]
this is all we need this the this is the
rosean content we
[Music]
need okay so we're Roseanne really took
a slide is in your hometown in Chicago
years ago when uh she was married to Tom
Arnold they were coked out of their
minds and they went to a Cubs game and
they went to um sing um the national
anthem I think it was and they just made
a mockery of it which is their right
they went on the field and they sang the
national
anthem go look it up right now go look
it up I don't know if I've ever heard
this story go what the [__] are you
serious this is like this is like so
everyone loved Roseanne Bar until this
moment and then like [__] her um now I'm
not gonna say that this is the reason
why you should hate Roseanne Bar I'm not
gonna say that this is during the Cubs
game
yeah go go look it up and Tom you know
everyone knows that her and Tom Arnold
[__] drug addicts and they were just
you know stoned out of their minds all
the time and the more money they got the
more drugs they did and I think Tom has
talked about it several times and he's a
wild
[__] and of course Tom is like
the the the polar opposite in politics
as Roseanne yeah people are posting also
in the uh in the Discord where she was
she was dressed up as Hitler cooking
cookies I don't know if you remember
that oh yes yeah and know I know that
people are like oh she was racist I get
that but I'm saying specifically when
her show got cancelled there's an
interview that she did she's like I
didn't know that Valerie um Obama
administration employee I think is who
it was she was
like uh no this was 1990s so I was born
I just wasn't very old well I know that
I but I know somebody somebody in the
chat was like gab wasn't born yet I was
born I just wasn't very old Tony sucks
Tony sucks Gabe rocks so it's obvious
that he was he was
born here we go I found it I found it
but yeah I've never known this send it
over here send it over here I did I did
oh okay okay is this oh this is on
YouTube all right hang on let me let me
get
this I can't believe I've never heard of
this you've never heard of this this
like I know I know everything else about
Roseanne and what she's done and how
she's just like well now you're gonna
change your [__] down but yeah
wow such a good singer the beginning of
a new career yeah I'm
s between
gameson and you see there that it's Tom
Arnold greator League San Diego welome
to America's most famous working woman
oh it was in San Diego
yeah was in
Chicago yeah I was like ah this isn't in
my exicon of Chicago
[Applause]
[Music]
history like is this supposed to be like
a performance piece or something like
performative art so she's performing
they're booing her because of what she
yeah yeah and but I'm is is that is like
she I mean obviously I've never heard
her sing before and I can't imagine
she's very good at singing But was she
trying to be funny what well I mean it's
rosean this like a bit she was doing she
was like I'm gonna [__] butcher it on
purpose a lot of people got pissed off
because she can't sing and they got
pissed off because they thought she was
mocking well she can't sing where of
[__] and she she had her fingers in her
ears you can see she had her fingers in
her ears and a lot of people said she
was mocking the National Anthem with
their fingers ears and what she was
actually doing was trying to drown out
the booze so she could hear herself sing
right but they were booing because why
in the [__] would you let Roseanne
Bar you could say the same thing so I
mean I think people knew I mean maybe
people didn't know what they were
expecting with Roseanne Bar but uh at a
Milwaukee Bucks game Flav of flave I
don't know if you saw this recently like
in the last couple weeks saying the
national anthem during the game why
would they do that why would they do
that and many people are like well you
guys had to have known that he wasn't
gonna be good and also people watching
they're like people watching they're
like maybe the people watching shouldn't
get so pissed because you knew what you
were about to get right you could and
you listen to it right so it's and I was
like oh man it was it was it wasn't very
good it was very bad I mean it wasn't it
was better than Roseanne Bar we'll say
that but it wasn't good and what you
would expect when somebody's like yeah
we're going to have someone sing the
national anthem you're like whether or
not you like the national anthem at
least have someone that's like okay I
can sing the song and it's actually like
you know bearable you know what you know
what I ask I'll ask was she dressed
appropriately because the next Bonet I'm
trying to I'm trying to transition the
next Bonet Ronda santz Gabe Sanchez I
have an image here of Ronda santis in
Kimberly guilfoil drag um this is a real
image this is real this is not this is
definitely definitely not AI here is
Ronda Santa meat
Bowl this looks like if this looks like
a the shell of an Eminem came off and it
melted a little bit and like some of the
peanuts were broken maybe it's a pudding
maybe it's a pudding ball a pudding ball
could be a there's there's like tapioca
balls right like maybe this is like a a
chocolate pudding ball right well let me
show you I got I got video footage of
this okay of Ronda santis dressed up in
Kimberly Gil foil drag I've got I got
video footage of this and this is real
footage this is not this is not AI this
is [__] real footage I found it
online so it's got to be real
right here's here's footage of Rhonda
Sant wow this is this is it this is a
video of what we just
saw that is a long run wa wait wait wait
hang on hang on hang on hang on hang on
I I think I think I'm wrong about this
again I think I I corrected myself
earlier this is this is this person
walks way too way too well in high heels
for this to be Ronda STIs I can't I
don't know also hold on I'm just gonna
say this again can we talk about how
long that walkway is that's true I know
like it seems like it's never ending
like where are it's almost like they did
it on purpose I don't know it's almost
it's almost
like the venue that they chose they're
like ah well we can't walk on the ground
here look at this thing this thing is
like half the length of a football field
what is going on well it's probably
because this is like a a a [__]
cattle field and you know there's cow
pies everywhere so they let they let
their supporters walk on the cowp keeps
walking but they have an elevated
platform because we know that the manga
Elite can and then she has to go she has
to go left uhuh to then get to wherever
she's going well hey this is Ronda
Santos this is not she this is he don't
don't don't be making fun of Ronda
Santos as in the shart Army will get
really [__] offended if you make fun
of them okay do not do not mock or make
fun of Ronda Santos all right all right
I'm just saying don't definitely
definitely don't put him on bone end of
the week so why was he on bone of the
week other than he dresses in drag is
that why he's on bone of the week I mean
pretty much I mean it was it was the
fact or was it that like K people at the
border this uh I don't know I mean I I
mainly I mainly interpret as there were
multiple moments that were leading up to
Ronda Sis's debate night where he could
not walk in his own shoes and that's
because the guy wears lifts that's what
happens when you're constantly walking
like this and you haven't been properly
trained or experienced enough like a
woman or a drag queen or anyone else who
just prefers to walk in heels when you
when you go after those communities and
you make fun of them and you say that
they're the devil and they're the
problem with society and all this stuff
and then you self use heels and can't
walk in
them n man we ain't doing that [__]
here's a couple videos here's here's one
here of Ronda santis walking in in heels
like um uh like like Kimberly Gil foil
well not as well but here here's I'll
mute this he's talking to V ramaswami
which he's also on the bone head of the
week here yeah now but here's here's Ron
and it looks someone said it looks like
he I think it was Aaron rupard said he
looks like he walks like has
gout clearly Ron needs to go to a drag
show yeah and be taught how to walk in
high heels like
clearly Ron drag queens are not your
enemy here they are your friend they
could teach you how to properly walk so
that you can properly convince people
that you're taller than you are because
I know you know you got small dick
energy and you really you really need it
also it it the it also makes me feel
like he's got like corns like on his
feet and so he's like ah
ah I mean if you were walking in Boots
like that all the time wouldn't you
eventually develop some [__] you
know brises or you know corns that's
quite like I said before I was like I
don't know if Ronda santis is into foot
binding like the Chinese
like but oh [__] I'm trying to find the
one where he almost almost falls off the
stage but you know we got to move on
[__] so Ronda santis welcome again to
the boneh head of the week sorry you
didn't win pal just like you're not
gonna win in the primary oh poor Ronnie
but but I will say this he definitely
should not drop out he yeah should not
no no continue he's been doing better
he's been doing better about these ads
against and these other like you know D
Oh you mean the anti-gay anti-gay vly
big ads the Nazi ads is that is that the
on you're uh no no not that one
there's not that one the other one the
other one no attacking attacking Donald
Trump oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah well
they're spending Republican dollars to
attack Donald Trump that's always good
um which you know another person that's
going to be rerunning that's gonna have
a hell of a time of winning her election
is the alpha cook this week Lauren
bobbert I'm assuming that you put her as
the alpha cook because she got totally
dunked in the trash about I don't know
like
how to do procedure on the house floor
she's only been a congress person for
over almost three years now and she
still doesn't know she is uh bone
definitely definit definitely bonee head
you know you know who else on a side
note yeah you know who else I almost put
on the bone head of the week for the
cuck or the the pole uh for the for the
uh dishonorable mention oh okay yeah I
almost put Jill Stein on there oh well I
mean we've got a lot to talk about with
Putin's puppet there Jill Stein here is
um here's stenny Hoyer and you know
what's funny about this because me and
Cliff Cliff was on the show yesterday
and we talked about this clip and I I
knew Cliff would have some good Insight
on this because he's been on the hill
before and he's someone who you know
probably watches a lot of floor debate
especially when it gets heated and it's
important so you know if you watch it
enough and c-span's boring as [__] right
it's like watching [__] paint dry
most of the time but if you watch it for
I don't know just a little bit you just
watch the debate happen when it's normal
boring stuff you would figure out oh
that's how it goes like this is the
order this is how why you have to
address the speaker whoever is presiding
even if it's a substitute presiding you
know that there's time and you have to
give time and yield time back and all
kinds of weird stuff that doesn't happen
in everyday life but it happens in an
official proceeding but stenny hoer here
actually caught off guard that he
[__] stumped her so badly because I
don't think he intended to do this this
is just what happed I mean it was just a
simple question right well let let's
watch let's watch and I ask the gentle
lady to yeld for a
question's recognized it's not my time I
ask you to yeld I have reserved you're
free to speak yes I'm asking if you'll
yeld for
question so Lauren bber In This Moment
clearly does not understand that stenny
oror has to address the speaker whenever
you're whenever you're in the house
chamber or the Senate chamber you have
to address it is procedure that you have
to address the speaker that's why when
they're in that's why they're when
they're in the house chamber and they're
addressing they say Mr Speaker or Mrs
speaker yeah that's or if they're in the
Senate they say Mr President or Mrs
president you're not talking to the
president of United States you're
talking to the president of the
Senate but Lauren Bard apparently has
been on the capital here for three
[__] years and still doesn't know
this and that stinny warrier if he's
going to ask her a question in procedure
to address her he has to get permission
on the house floor from the person who
controls the time to ask the question to
her not to the speaker but stenny orer
here obviously doesn't understand that
she's a [__] Mega bonehead and
doesn't understand this but he keeps
going watch this sure ask your question
what funds in this bill are used uh for
the purposes you uh okay are opposed
to sorry I couldn't hear oh oh I'm sorry
I couldn't hear you U because of my
stupidity I I really um my St she did
not yeah and I love sorry I didn't hear
what he said you heard what he asked you
you knew the question and here's the
thing you got [__]
busted he stumped you and it was a basic
question which is like where are these
funds that you're talking about and then
she goes on to say as well watch she
like oh it's precautionary what the [__]
are you talking about well here let's
let's watch what she says which is
ridiculous and he stumps her here again
gentlemen I was getting clarification
this is
precautionary precautionary for
what he's honestly like what wait what
what what's hilarious is is that her
staffer now and let me show you here
okay her staffer is sitting behind her
here this is her staffer now this is the
idiot that works for the idiot because
this idiot doesn't even know what
precautionary means um she's telling her
that it's just say it's precautionary
she's like okay that sounds that sounds
really official that sounds really
[__] smart actually so that's what
I'm gonna say I'm going to say that's
precautionary let's see how it works out
yes I understand I understand what that
are that are in place that are allowing
The Refuge of illegal aliens in these
cities and there's an influx in crime
and drugs I understand these cities and
there's no there's no way for these
folks to even report what is taking
place because you know what's funny is
if you look at these two faces they're
like yeah we're totally owning him like
he's totally getting know here she's
like yeah we got you because those Libs
in their Democratic cities are alling
these illegals to come in watch what
stiny oror does they're protected under
this fake policy that has been created
that is subduing the actual rule of law
that we have in the con
of the United States no no not the
consti I'm say but what You' said is
none of the funds in this bill can be
spent for that objective and that is
precautionary I want what funds are in
this bill to be spent for that objective
I I have seen this Administration use
all sorts of funds none that's what she
actually means none now to understand
exactly what is happening here is this
is an appropriation hearing and this is
an appropriation debate and she's she is
putting on the floor an amendment to
make sure that spending our our money
isn't spent in this way and he's like
it's not spent in this way so what the
[__] are you talking about why are you
introducing an amendment to not spend
funds that aren't spent that way anyways
what the [__] are you talking about this
is like putting a Band-Aid where you
don't have a boo boo what are you
talking about like you're just wearing a
Band-Aid okay Nelly with the Band-Aid on
your face you don't actually have a boo
boo you're just wearing the Band-Aid
just to be cool
hey man it was cool it was cool it was
you're right it was [__] cool but
yeah Lauren bber here you know she's
like I'm gonna own the lives by telling
you that you you know we don't want to
use the funds this way and he's like
wait what funds are you talking about
right I don't know are you juicing the
beetle again and here's the thing it
like the question was asked because he
was like wait maybe there's some
confusion because I imagine right he was
I imagine his initial reaction and I'm
sure it would be true for most people
which be like wait you just said hold on
hold on is there something in this bill
that I know about with these funds let
me ask a clarifying
question probably not thinking that he
was going to just set a trap for her and
she was gonna fall for it he did he
really he honestly I don't trying to set
a trap what do you hold on I'm sorry
what are you what what funds are you
talking what are you what are you
referring to and she was like oh These
funds he's like well there are no funds
and he's like are you this dumb and he
goes well it's precautionary yes oh God
she is thatb she should have said yes I
am yes I am yes my name is Lauren Boer
hi I'm the problem it's me I only know
how to vape and play Pocket hockey with
a
boy oh so let's move on I love shovels
and I love rakes right and I don't have
much other than that going on uh though
I do like guns and I do like giving
people bloody diarrhea at my former
restaurant well speaking of bloody
diarrhea let's go to the dishonorable
mention James kin on comr speaking of
bloody diarrhea so this guy subpoena
this guy subpoena James Biden not the
president the president's brother he
penis James Biden about the $200,000
that Joe
Biden received in a repayment of a loan
on 200 Grand the funny part is about
this folks because this is hot cribs and
misers and he's going to imit
pment him just James comr is gonna
impeach Joe Biden over James Biden's
subpoena the funny part is James Comer's
got a skeleton in his closet gab Sanchez
can you tell us what that skeleton is
one I would say he's got multiple well
he is a republican he is a republican so
basically the there's a Daily Beast
report that came out that was like we
looked into these documents and these
reports and what we have is that James
comr and his own brother had multiple
land swaps over the years and not only
that
it couldn't be it couldn't be like James
comr and a business partners it
literally had to be the exact thing that
they're investigating Joe Biden for in
sub so then so then it was 200 so one
one one or one of them was $200,000
given to his brother and the exact
amount that the other one was that yes
you can't make this [__] up it is not
even and and and and on top of that it's
not even like oh he gave him a loan for
money
he gave him $200,000 and it went through
a shell company right so when you're
like oh I you know I'm giving a loan to
a family member and they can pay it back
whenever why would you do it through a
shell comp like why do you have to hide
it through a company that is not in your
name why do you have to cover it up I I
don't know maybe you're taking you
learned the art of the deal from Donald
Trump and that's why you do it or maybe
because you're just corrupt and you're a
criminal so when you've got James comr
being like James
Biden and Joe Biden are illegally
transferring $200,000 gotta give 10% to
the big guy here he is signing the suben
he's like yeah I'm gonna get these
bidens for doing this
thing that I did with my brother that's
really weird I don't know why you would
try to criminalize [__] that you've
already done that's really [__] it's
like an anchor man he's like I'm Ron
Burgundy he's like I'm money
laundering I'm laundering large sums of
money well watch this I'm going to show
you a video here this is Jason
moscowitz of of Florida and he he's
signing a subpoena for for James Comer's
brother oh my God he's subpoena James
comr there's a lesson there's a there's
a lesson to be uh said again and again
well there a couple one do you think
they'll learn this lesson before they'll
never learn they'll never learn but the
two are uh the first
being every GOP accusation is a
confession okay that's one we've we've
known that to be true many many times
many many many many many many times the
second is the age-old one of do not
throw stones in Glass Houses you
hypocritical [__] you're going after the
president anything you can find to
impeach the guy you haven't found
anything you literally had a hearing you
brought in the business partner for
Hunter Biden and the business partner
was like now this Ain I never heard
anything I wasn't aware of that I can
tell you no there was no loan Andy bigs
left that little closed door hearing
because they didn't want to televise it
because they knew what they were getting
and he's like yeah there was no I don't
know anything about that I have no idea
what loans they're talking about there
was no payment there was no bribe and
then on top of that you've got their
whistleblower and their informant that
just go missing here and there because
they're in the Spy game and then you
find out that one of them was actually a
Chinese spy who also worked with
Iran so then you've got all of these
people they're like wait wait wait this
doesn't look so good so then they have a
Committee hearing because they're like
we're gonna impeach Joe Biden and every
time they brought up evidence you had
people like Byron Donald's skew cut and
manipulate text messages between Hunter
Biden James Biden uh discussing Joe
Biden
and saying like oh this is clearly going
to the big guy Joe Biden but really it's
talking about hey I need money can you
help me out you know what you know what
though I you know what before we move on
to the winner here Bon of the week I
wanna I want to say the dishonorable
mention here James comr maybe he's on to
something he's like look I committed
crime doing this so I'm gonna try to
find the same crime that I committed Joe
Biden commitment so that's what we're
going to do well it's it's also it's
also because you know how were like oh
in order to Catch a Criminal you got to
think like a criminal right in order
Republicans are like no we're good we
got to be we're going to in order to in
order to Catch a Criminal we have to
become criminals that's right we have to
go deep undercover and it's like no no
you guys don't understand we had to
learn the ways of corrupt criminal
politicians to catch the corrupt
criminal politicians so don't worry yes
we may have benefited financially and
yes we may have pedal our influence for
financial gain but don't worry don't
worry it was all to catch the real
criminals the Democrats who aren't doing
what they're saying they're doing just
like our bonehead winner of the week who
says [__] that he isn't gonna do because
he's an idiot I you know I've I've been
asking the audience here when VC will be
appropriately Andrew Yang you remember
Andrew Yang remember that guy yeah he
was like I'm a Democrat yeah I'm a Dem
like that he was like I'm a Democrat and
then people like no you're not right
well he he was saying wild crazy stuff
on the stage people like yeah I'm in the
Yang gang and I believe what he says and
you're like wow why do you believe what
he says that's really wild and and then
vet comes along he's like yeah I'm I'm
Andrew Yang but a fascist you know what
I mean and they're like oh yeah I
believe what he says because he said it
why do you believe it I don't know he
said it V said it it's really wild so
there could be a thousand different
reasons why V Rama Swami Rama swampy is
on um bone end of the week but why did
he why do you think he won what was the
reason why you think he won the probably
it had to do with the fact that he made
himself into the villain when it came to
the debates he went up there and was
like I'm gonna attack everyone and I'm
gonna say some stuff now again we've
talked about this before it's like you
can attack people who are candidates but
keep the family out of it even though
Republicans who
love to say h don't don't talk about the
kids you know Alina Haba don't talk
about Trump's kids functioning adults
part of an organization that was
committing fraud but whatever you have
Republicans who are also like we're
gonna attack Obama's kids and everyone's
like whoa dude they're [__] under 18
at this age maybe don't do that that's
not cool you can attack them as a
candidate them as a politician whatever
but keep the family out of it keep it
civil to some degree come on let's have
some decency you know got to protect the
kids and re ramaswami goes on stage and
you know tries to attack Nikki Haley
over Tik Tock and China and then brings
up her daughter as as if that was a
smart move which you then hear the crowd
respond in a way that wasn't so
favorable well you know there's one
thing that he said was right on this
stage I'm I'm not gonna I'm not here and
I am upset about what happened last
night we've become a party of losers go
back is that the beginning of the clip
because there's a question that was
asked about President Trump and I think
well okay well give me the full clip
well no okay I don't here the question
was the question well here I'll try to
find it but basically uh the tldr was
the question that was asked to V
ramaswami was basically how do you
differ like what's the problem you know
do you see an issue with Donald Trump
and he doesn't address it because he's
not there to criticize president Trump
the Way's PL he's a PL he then went well
the real problem is the Republican
party and then skips over it and then
goes we're we're losers we're lose it
why do you think that is Well's you
think that is let's listen party here
and I am upset about what happened last
night we've become a party of losers at
the end become okay I am going to
disagree this isn't right you've always
been a party a party of losers right
right okay well let's let's 2017 2018
2019 2020 2021 20 2 2023 it's going to
happen in 2024 you guys think that
abortion is popular you guys think
taking away women's rights are popular
you you think that you know legalizing
marijuana is not popular you think
anything that is beneficial to us as
Americans Health Care
education safety all of these things
they go with the opposite the unpopular
opinion and then go this is exactly what
people want
and then they're like wait wait wait
wait wait why did we lose they're still
doing that after Tuesday's election
we're losers why let's listen to why he
thinks they're losers end of the day
there a cancer in the Republican
establishment and speak the truth I mean
since Ronald McDaniel took over as
chairwoman of the RC in 2017 we've lost
2018 2020 2022 no red wave that never
came we got trounced last night in 2020
so they're going to blame it on the
woman you see you notice it you notice
like oh we're going to kill women's
rights and we got TR by trying to take
away what they're all trying to do the
woman the woman it's the woman's fault
woman everyone is trying to blame Ron
McDaniel for it where you have to
understand yeah sure maybe she played a
part in this whole like loser strategy
but if Donald Trump is the person that
you have propped up since he was elected
in 2016 and took over in 2017
and even after 2020 and 2021 after the
January 6 Insurrection you felt like it
was necessary to still back this guy
Kevin McCarthy went on a whole Rebrand
and Rehabilitation tour for Donald Trump
Ronald MCD was like no the RNC isn't
going to pay these bills if he decides
to run for president Donald Trump's go
[__] yourself Ronald McD's like I'll
still support Trump and now she has made
herself into the enemy of this party
because they're looking for anyone to
take blame other than Donald Trump other
than the party themselves and say oh
guys look we're attacking these people
marginalized communities women and so
forth taking away these rights in alible
rights and everyone's saying and
everyone's saying oh it's not
popular and they're voting against us
guys why why does this keep happening to
us let me show you Rona McDaniel here
absolutely and maybe VC ramas mamy is
right it's it's definitely Rona McDaniel
Daniel Romney's fault here let's listen
to her say how she wanted and how she's
taking credit for getting rid of roie
Wade I got rid of Ro v Wade I'm the one
that got rid of roie Wade I was able to
do it and I was very honored to do it do
you believe in punishment for abortion
yes or no as a principal the answer is
that there has to be some form of
punishment for the woman yeah there has
to be some form there of course remains
a vital role for the federal government
in protecting unborn life
has ever done more for right to life
than Donald Trump roie Wade they won
they finally won uh the Iowa bill was
signed and they wouldn't have been able
to do anything if I wasn't able to do
what I
did Rona McDaniel there talking about
how she
yikes oh wait that wasn't Rona McDaniel
oh we're blaming it on the wrong person
it feels like he's like excuse me excuse
me I'm the best pro-life candidate out
there babies babies don't be aborted
unless they're mine um Donald Trump
attacks
women micro
Johnson uh micro speaker micro Johnson
attacks
women Matt Gates attacks women Lauren
bobbert attacks her own gender Margery
Taylor green attacks her own gender
these are people who do not Nancy ma who
says that she is a victim of rape when
she was 16
and stands for women's rights yet when
it comes down to it she supports every
candidate that is against abortion that
is against women's rights that is
against bodily autonomy she goes oh I
I'm a I'm a bit of a a fire brand in the
Republican party I vote against the
party when I deem it's necessary well
when you look at your claim of being
proman and your voting record it's the
complete opposite you line
ly sack of [__] and that's the whole
Republican party they attack women's
rights and even it's like you guys have
not learned your lesson you'll continue
to do that again and again and I'm not
going to stop you from embarrassing
yourselves because you're going to find
out the hard way which is in 2024 when
you try to do this National ban which is
not going to pass the
Senate not going to it's not going to be
passed across Joe Biden's
desk they're going to continue to be
like you know what we got to do
we got to take away women's rights like
that's right dog you you've seen this
you've seen this play you've seen this
movie you know the ending you've seen it
again and again this isn't Goosebumps
where you're gonna pick your own ending
here Choose Your Own Adventure you've
seen the ending it's not going to change
for you you go after women and women are
going to say [__] you even Republican
women in their own party are like nah no
no no we're not going to do that we're
not going to take away my rights and
you're not going to take away my
partner's rights
here's the party of losers as VC says
one other thing I want to point out here
that VC said at this
um debate if you want to call it that
one one more thing one more thing here
real quick before we goign I will turn
over my yield my time to you and frankly
look the people they are cheering from
losing in the Republican Party think
about who's moderating this debate this
should be Tucker Carlson
joean viewership asking questions that
GOP primary voters actually care about
bring in yeah the real issues that they
care about I think this is a go back to
it because he I think this clip he
points out a certain favorite person of
mine more people into our party you
think the Democrats we got Christan
weler here okay you think the Democrats
would goes we got Christian Walker
debate they wouldn't do it Greg gutfield
you think they'd hire Greg gutfield but
the fact that he was like we got
Christian Walker you sure you you you
think that's a brag dude that's a flex
I don't know man that's a weird Flex bro
he's he's flexing all over the place
that's why he flexed his way to the
winner bent of the week Gabe Sanchez
let's give the V Rama
swampy is
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
oh oh V Rama swampy I am so happy that
you won bonehead of the week and I am so
happy you're on your way to be Andrew
yanged is that the first time he's ever
appeared on bone head of the week no no
no no he's he's been on bonehead of the
week before has he won his first time
winning it might be his first time
winning well get used to it get used to
it VC because you're get used to losing
because you're not going to win
anything that's been this week's bone
head of the
[Music]
[Applause]
week hand of the week our favorite
segment one of the oldest segments that
we have here on the JY Michaels podcast
I appreciate you joining us guy with the
last name Sanchez even though it appears
that I am not near nearly as popular as
you are I wish I had the song that I
could I could play here but it appears
it's not in the um in the queue there
anymore when it was a one time thing
people on the show got it once and that
was
it g rocks yeah if you if you missed it
you can just go back and and and get it
there you have any announcements what do
you got going on what do you got going
on over there what was that L all right
um I've got a what was that episode I'm
working on right now which is swell
drags Jim Jordan again uh because Jim
Jordan was like let's talk about
anti-Semitism and then swall was like
all right let's talk about that tweet
from 2022 where you praised Kanye Elon
and Trump and this was all during the
moment that Kanye was like on this
anti-semitic tie rate and and just
spiral uh I've got another one about uh
that I need to release but I wanted to
wait till after the Trump trial kind of
cooled down after these like big star
Witnesses came up uh it's going to be
about a a magga comedian that's going to
be coming out I'm probably going going
to do one on the I'm I'm gonna do one on
V actually and just basically talk about
V being the villain and how he's not
popular you look at polls in Iowa you
look at polls in other places like hands
down majority of people are like we
don't trust the guy is this is this the
mag is this the magga comedian is it mag
does she makes an appearance because
there I will say this during the hey
let's talk about V ramaswami during the
debates I do have a moment where I'm
like let's go see how the rally was
doing at the same time and she makes a
cameo oh okay well I don't know and I
don't know this other Mega if this other
Mega uh comedian is a singer or not but
you know it
happens Tony Su
[Music]
G many people are saying many people are
saying Tony sucks
[Music]
R that's a really good tune actually I'm
not going to lie it's got of ring to you
know I mean Tony the rat is in the lab
dude Gabe rocks so don't forget to go to
what was that live with Gabe SES every
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday and also
follow him on YouTube because you're not
going to want to miss a single live
episode but you're also not going to
want to miss any single episode of what
was that go to youtube.com am gab
Sanchez you can down in description
below and find him there as well so go
follow his YouTube channel as always
I'll be here every single weekday and I
appreciate everyone everyone going and
grabbing even my dog hates Ted Cruz this
weekend I will release even my cat hates
Ted Cruz and we'll throw another other
couple names in there too we'll get some
coffee mugs we'll get some more t-shirts
we'll get some stickers for you up in
the store so be watching on social media
and the YouTube Community page and that
Facebook page we got a new Facebook
group going over there I know Gabe hates
oh he hates Facebook I just don't new we
got a new we got wasn't you know it just
doesn't work yeah he doesn't like face I
don't like Facebook either but we like
the people over on Facebook also follow
us on Discord the library of democracy
is having a book club over there in the
Discord the obstacle is the way Ryan
holiday is the first book they're also
doing Rachel mat's audio book where
they're having discussions after they
listen to it you should check it out go
to the Discord and go to the Tony
michaels.com find the book club link
there take you straight to the book club
so you can join the Discord um and you
can do that also I want to thank
everyone who's buying the the tattoo
merch that's going like hot cakes a lot
of people in the chat today said they
got their t-shirts they got their
hoodies so make sure you get your
t-shirts and your hoodies it's getting
cold outside and you don't want to you
don't want to go without this machine
killing fascism while it's getting cold
um so go grab your tattoo merch go to
the Tony
michaels.com oh boy oh boy same time
same place next week I promise I'll be
here
it's been real it's been real wait wait
wait I I can't do it we gota do it one
more
[Music]
time Tony
suck G
Ro same
time same place next week
Monday Tony
[Music]
suck Ser up
[__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
do you believe in punishment for
abortion yes or no is a principle the
answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah there has to be some
form do you believe in punishment for
abortion yes or no is a principle the
answer is that there has to be some form
of punishment for the woman yeah there
has to be some form do you believe in
punishment for abortion yes or no as a
principle the answer is that there has
to be some form of punishment for the
woman yeah there has to be some form do
you believe in punishment for abortion
yes or no is a principle the answer is
that there has to be some form of
punishment